for me as a man like women um change
their minds women say they want
something and then when they get it
they don't want it anymore and and
that's something that i've seen as a man
throughout my whole entire life like a
woman will tell you that they actually
want something like they want this nice
guy or they want this thing and then
they get it and they're like
it's a bit too
nice guys we wouldn't hate man
we don't like too sweet or too
too how you say
player you know we like player and we
like sweet it's like a mix you know you
need to mix otherwise it's going to be
too boring or too
how do you say too traumatized because
players you know they can be a bit
narcissist and they can be a bit
traumatic so it's a bit it's about it
makes about balance if you are too much
this or too much that of course we get
it like ah
okay so can i say as a man right that
that perfect balanced man that you're
looking for doesn't exist i know and so
you
you having that in your head and i think
that's a lot of time why women get
disappointed with men because they've
created this actual man in their head
that actually doesn't exist right and so
you're looking for this man and you
think oh that's the one that's like he
doesn't exist no woman has found the
quote-unquote perfect man yet they're
looking for him though and i think
that's because you guys have been sold a
disney version of what um relationships
are you know like um per there are just
good men or and good women right out
there and i think that this whole oh a
man should be this we want this we want
that he's got to be he's got to have an
edge to him but then he's got to be nice
and he's got to be loyal but then he's
got to be a homemaker but then he can't
be tuned out is that it's like how this
list is like how long
what what is this list how it is the
list
from men about women
our list is very simple
tell us
don't talk too much
okay be cooperative
uh
be a good mother if you if you've got if
you've got children
um
and and cooperate like talk too much
what the hell because met because we
don't because men like peace so
no women don't like peace
women don't like peace i don't i i
generally don't think women like peace i
think once women get peace they get
bored i think women like excitement yeah
i think they like something a little bit
like a little bit more edgy a little bit
more exciting because if you give a
woman if you give a woman too much peace
she's like oh this is a little bit
boring whereas men will be happy to be
bored for the rest of their life chill
with a woman have this woman as their
woman and be like all right cool this is
my woman for the rest of her life did
you know women only swipe right between
five and fifteen percent of the time on
dating apps where men swipe right fifty
to sixty percent of the time
why do you think that is why because
women have have to be more selective we
carry a kid for nine months so it's like
in our dna in my opinion
where men were more programmed to like
spread their seed and like women have a
long list of requirements typically as
that prerequisite which sometimes are
probably unreasonable
yeah i think women get disappointed by
their own
by their own um expectations
expectations yes and i think your ex i
think women's expectations are quite
deluded
if i'm totally honest i think it's like
you get i i've known a few women who
have said
oh i wanted this guy and i got with him
but he was too nice i said but you said
you wanted a nice guy
yeah but he was too what the that's too
nice to me what do you mean what do you
mean yeah he was just a bit boring it
was a bit squared he didn't have any
like edge to him it's like
that is why when women go for these
quote-unquote dogs they have that
excitement they have that that that
spice to them they have that edge to
them and then when that man acts the way
he's supposed to act as that type of guy
you get disappointed you're like he's a
dog he's like no well you picked him you
picked him because you saw that edge in
him
i agree with that yeah i think there's
like extreme there's like the too sweet
guy
and there is like the one
the player the excitement but there is
like i i never met a guy that has both
i'm the best guy
that has very sweet that was my
seven-year
relationship my ex and then i met
another guy for a year and a half
and he gave me all that excitement and
then trauma
and right skill healing
right this is not me normal so why did
you so with this episode if you don't
mind me asking so the seven year guy
what was bad about that like was he what
was bad about that relationship
he's a great guy like when it comes to
heart like he's a great human you know
is he has a good heart i just feel like
he would make me jealous on purpose like
in front of me i don't know why you know
like i was like what the [ __ ] i feel
like it was probably insecure
um and that's your problem and if you
want to talk about it let's talk about
i'm i'm here to listen but i'm not here
to experience your pain or triggering
your frustrations you know if you get
triggered don't put it on me
um
so yeah he was making me jealous and
then on my birthday for example i
actually got traumatized because
uh honestly
so he was next to me and a girl was next
to him
and
he was talking to her i don't mind talk
who the [ __ ] want
but then he
that's what i'm telling you right now is
because he was talking to her and he was
putting his hand on her leg and it was
like glue on his hand he didn't just
touch and you know took off it just let
his hand there
like had glue for five minutes and then
i pinched myself and on my birthday i
just felt like
what
you know
sorry
oh sorry
wow
i didn't mean to like make you tell that
story and like get upset
but yeah
anyway
so yeah it's my birthday you know it's
your day it's a day that you cannot
forget you know because you're gonna
always remember and
[Music]
it's hard when
it's
situations like that that
make you
think about
just other situations because seven
years is a long time
and
if i were you i'd be like i'm for the
streets too forget him i'm out here
i'm gonna go around and find something
better so
it's
it's hard to want to
find the person that you you want and
you have these things and you
essentially get that person
but they
is is what you want but at the end it's
like not what you want you're like i
never i never thought that that person
would have done that but it's like we
we cast our vision on what we
um
what we what we want but we don't see
past it's like our hand is like our hand
is our vision but we can't see past our
hand because our hands in the way and
what what they really are is behind our
hand but we don't move it because like
this is what i want this is what i see
and i want this but what they really are
is behind it and i feel like we as women
have
have standards which we should for
ourselves
but it's so
astronomical that we're not able to
really see who a person is so stuff like
that happens because we have these
standards and this image of who we want
in our lives that we can't see the
reflex or we see them but we don't we
don't acknowledge them or we don't um
say anything about we brush it off like
oh
it was just plain they were just funny
but in the end it's like man
what is it that us as women really want
do we all want men that are over six
foot
or do we really want someone that is no
matter how boring they are that is going
to
care for us in those
days where we should if we should be
celebrated and that aren't going to step
out are not going to do things that they
know are going to hurt us
yeah definitely
but that was not my relationship with
seven years that i had with my ex that
was the relationship there recently for
a year okay